How are you, Cristian Cásseres greets you with
his brief News Now report in
Spanish, they detect the first case of the
South African variant of cobi 19 here in
the state of Nevada, according to doctors at the
University of Wine Nevada, the
infected person traveled to South Africa but
was not contagious  when he traveled to his
home country authorities have taken steps
to drag away anyone who
might have had contact with this
person state officials
remind the public that they should
self-quarantine when traveling
abroad to control the
spread of the disease i
heard these  New changes are about to be
implemented in
Nevada regarding vaccination people 65 years of age or
older are already eligible walk-
ins can now receive the vaccine at
Asier Points High School or
Carmen Sánchez but remember that
Carmen Centro closes at noon  there is also a
vaccination center in the
bancor but there is an appointment we have more  More
information on all vaccination sites
and who is eligible on
our page news now dotcom
the loosening of
coronavirus restrictions in nevada is prompting
more reopening in the tourist area of
las vegas in particular some
shows including the
comedian show that is  in luxor is
scheduled to open this weekend
after being closed for a year
restrictions on places where
the public can gather has limited
gatherings to 100 people or a capacity
of 35% whichever is less other businesses and
activities are preparing to
increase your capacities to 50% by
next March 15 and finally we
take a look at the temperatures
today a very sunny day is anticipated
with temperatures reaching the low 60
degrees the winds will pick up by
tomorrow and a system will pass through the region
during the  weekend that will bring cold
to the valley I anticipated winds up to 30
miles per hour  For the next few
days I am Cristian Casares and this is your
brief informative on igloos on the side in
Spanish Happy Friday
[Music]